BUT FIRST, THE LAWLESSNESS OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THAT THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE" ."
OVER THE WEEKEND, DEMOCRATS BENT
OVER BACKWARDS.
NOT TO LAMENT THE OUTRAGEOUS
LACK OF TRUTHFULNESS BY FORMER
FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE,
BUT TO LAMENT INSPIRING.
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID WAS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST, I THINK,
CHARACTER FLAWS THAT WE SEE IN
HIM.
HE LACKS HUMAN DECENCY.
IT WAS CRUEL THE WAY HE DID THIS
TO FIRE SOMEONE LITERALLY HOURS
PENSION.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED WE
HAVE 90 DAYS TO GET McCABE
BEFORE HE RETIRES.
HE PUT OUT BASICALLY A HIT ON
HIM AND SAID DO THIS BEFORE HE
QUALIFIES FOR RETIREMENT.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN A PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES GO AFTER AN
INDIVIDUAL.
THIS IS AWFULLY MEAN-SPIRITED.
>> Laura: FRANKLY, HE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN SACKED A LONG TIME AGO
HAVE BEEN SACKED A LONG TIME AG
AGO.
YOU NOTICE WITH THE DEMOCRATS
WEREN'T DISCUSSING?
BUT LET'S FACE IT, THE
GOVERNMENT HERE FOLLOWED A
METICULOUS PROCESS AND THEY DID
IT ALL BY THE BOOK, WHICH IS
GOOD.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
INSPECTOR GENERAL FORWARDED ITS
FINDINGS TO THE FBI OFFICE OF
HER SPECIAL THOUGH MY
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
IT WAS THEY WHO DETERMINED THAT
HE SHOULD BE FIRED.
THAT'S A BIG DECISION.
JUST SO YOU ALL KNOW, THIS
OFFICE IS STAFFED WITH CAREER
PERSONNEL, NOT TRUMP LOYALISTS.
SO WHEN THE GOVERNMENT LEARNS OF
WRONGDOING, SHOULDN'T IT ACT
IMMEDIATELY WITHOUT REGARD OF
WHO CARES WHEN SOMEONE IS
RETIRING?
IF IT WAS WRONG, IT WAS WRONG.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT DID HERE.
YOU WILL NOTICE THAT NONE OF
McCABE DEFENDERS THAT YOU JUST
HEARD MENTION THE ACTUAL REASONS
FOR HIS DISMISSAL BECAUSE THOSE
ARE VERY INCONVENIENT.
HE'S CHARGED WITH LEAKING
INFORMATION ABOUT AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION, THE ONE INTO THE
CLINTON EMAIL SCANDAL TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS SAID
THAT McCABE LACKED CANDOR
ABOUT THOSE LEAKS AND AT TIMES
HE DID SO UNDER OATH.
THAT'S A BIG NO-NO.
WITH A RESPONSE ON FRIDAY NIGHT,
McCABE CLAIMS THE MEDIA LEAKS
WERE DONE WITH THE PERMISSION OF
THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JIM
COMEY.
THAT COULD BE A BIG PROBLEM FOR
COMEY, WHY?
HE HAS ARTIE TESTIFIED UNDER
OATH TO CONGRESS THAT HE DID NOT
ENGAGE IN LEAKING, NOR DID HE
AUTHORIZE ANY LEAKS.
SOMEONE IS LYING HERE.
AND WE HAVEN'T EVEN TALKED ABOUT
ANDREW McCABE'S CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
HE SHOULD HAVE RECUSED HIMSELF
FROM INVESTIGATING
HILLARY CLINTON SINCE HIS WIFE
JILL, WHEN SHE WAS RUNNING FOR
STATE OFFICE IN VIRGINIA,
RECEIVED NEARLY $468,000 FROM
CLINTON POWELL TERRY McAULIFFE
McAULIFFE.
FOR OTHER CLINTON FUNDERS
CONTRIBUTED $130,000 TO THE MET
CAMPAIGN.
NOT A BAD HAUL.
IF THAT DOESN'T CONSTITUTE AT
LEAST THE APPEARANCE OF A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST FOR HER
HUSBAND, WHO WAS INVESTIGATING
MRS. CLINTON?
IT IS PATENTLY OBVIOUS AT THIS
POINT THAT THE DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR MEDIA TOADIES WILL DEFEND
AND IGNORE ANY LAWLESSNESS SO
LONG AS IT ACHIEVES THEIR
POLITICAL END.
WHICH IS, WHAT, TO WIN BACK
POWER IN CONGRESS.
AND EVENTUALLY RUN
PRESIDENT TRUMP OUT OF OFFICE.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS.
THIS ENDORSEMENT OF LAWLESSNESS,
LOOKING THE OTHER WAY A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST, THIS ISN'T AN
ISOLATED INCIDENT FOR THE LEFT.
REMEMBER, THESE ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO APPLAUD THE
COMPASSION AND THE COURAGE OF
PUBLIC OFFICIALS WHO PUSH
SANCTUARY POLICIES IN CITIES
LIKE CHICAGO, HARTFORD,
CONNECTICUT, ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
THE AVERAGE WORKING PERSON HAS
TO SUFFER AS VIOLENT, ILLEGAL
ALIEN OFFENDERS WORLD FREE AFTER
BEING RELEASED FROM JAIL'S
PLACES LIKE OAKLAND AND L.A.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE.
THE RIOTING AND DESTRUCTION
FOLLOWING FREDDY GRAY'S DEATH.
DITTO FOR THE NIGHTS OF LOOTING
AND FIRES, THE TERRIBLE EVENTS
OF FERGUSON FOLLOWING A POLICE
SHOOTING OF MICHAEL BROWN.
RECALL THAT JURIES ACQUITTED THE
POLICE OFFICERS IN EACH CASE.
BY THE WAY, THE SAME TYPE OF
PEOPLE WHO, GOING BACK TO THE
OBAMA ERA, THEY DIDN'T BAT AN
EYE WHEN ERIC HOLDER DECLINED TO
PROSECUTE IRS OFFICIAL LOIS
LERNER FOR DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST CONSERVATIVE 501C GROUPS
AGAINST CONSERVATIVE 501C GROUP
GROUPS.
DIDN'T CARE THAT ERIC HOLDER
STONEWALLED CONGRESS REGARDING
THE FAST AND FURIOUS SCANDAL,
WHICH BY THE WAY, I FORGOT UNTIL
TODAY, WHICH LED TO A CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS RESOLUTION
AGAINST HOLDER.
AND OF COURSE, WE ALL REMEMBER
THERE WERE NO REPERCUSSIONS FOR
SUSAN RICE.
REMEMBER WHEN SHE WENT OUT AND
LIED TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ABOUT WHAT SPURRED THAT ATTACK
ON OUR GOVERNMENT COMPOUND IN
BENGHAZI LIBYA?
THE ONLY PERSON WHO WAS ACTUALLY
CHARGED AFTER FOUR AMERICANS
WERE KILLED THERE, INCLUDING THE
U.S. AMBASSADOR, WAS A MAN NAMED
NAMED -- HE WAS FOUND NOT GUILTY
OF 14 OF THE 18 COUNTS AGAINST
HIM.
UNBELIEVABLE, NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
LET US NOT FORGET THE DEMOCRATS
WHO ONCE PRIDED THEMSELVES ON
CARING ABOUT PROTECTING CIVIL
LIBERTIES.
IF THEY DON'T SEEM AT ALL
BOTHERED ABOUT USING THE VAST
POWER OF OUR INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES TO SPY ON MEMBERS OF
DONALD TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN TEAM.
ALTHOUGH THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
MEDIA SURROGATES SEEM FINE WITH
THIS BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY
APPROACH, I DO NOT THINK MOST
AMERICANS ARE.
CHECK THIS OUT.
IT'S A NEW MONMOUTH BULLET FINDS
THAT OVER HALF OF THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC IS EITHER VERY OR
SOMEWHAT WORRIED THAT THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT IS MONITORING THEIR
ACTIVITIES AND INVADING THEIR
PRIVACY.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ARE
NOTICING THE OVERREACH OF THE
DEEP STATE AND THEY DON'T LIKE
IT.
THIS MATTERS TO VOTERS.
IT SHOULD.
IF ANY OF US HAD DONE WHAT
McCABE DID, WE WOULD PROBABLY
ALREADY BE IN JAIL AND HE MAY
YET BE.
TO UNDERSTAND THE DANGERS AT
PLAY HERE, REMEMBER WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP VOWED TO REFORM
THE INTELLIGENCE SERVICES AS HE
CAME INTO OFFICE?
DO YOU RECALL THE CHILLING
RESPONSE OF
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER AT THE
TIME?
>> LET ME TELL YOU, YOU TAKE ON
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, THEY
HAVE SIX WAYS FROM SUNDAY AT
GETTING BACK AT YOU.
EVEN FOR A PRACTICAL, SUPPOSEDLY
HARD-NOSED BUSINESSMAN, HE'S
BEING REALLY DUMB TO DO THIS.
>> Laura: AND THE DEEP STATE
HAS TRIED TO GET TRUMP SIX WAYS
TO SUNDAY EVER SINCE.
AND EVEN WHEN THEY ARE CAUGHT,
AS McCABE WAS, DEMOCRATS WILL
DEFEND THEM BECAUSE THEY ALL
SHARE THE SAME GOAL.
AT EVERY LEVEL, THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE EITHER WILLINGLY ENABLED OR
TOLERATED LAWLESSNESS.
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST AND RANKED
BIAS WITHIN OUR GOVERNMENT,
BECAUSE THEY WANT POWER BACK.
AND THAT'S WHY THEY'VE CONTORTED
THEMSELVES INTO THESE PRETZELS
TO PROTECT HILLARY, AND THAT'S
WHY THEY ARE RELENTLESSLY
PURSUING DONALD TRUMP.
BUT I'M TELLING YOU, THIS
APPROACH MAY END UP BACKFIRING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S APPROVAL
NUMBERS HAVE GONE UP 4% TO 43%
IN THE LAST MONTH.
MAYBE I'M BEING TOO OPTIMISTIC,
MAYBE.
BUT I THINK AMERICANS HAVE A
STRONG SENSE OF INNATE FAIRNESS
AND ITS, IF THE DEMOCRATS IDEA
OF PUBLIC SERVICE IS SEEMING TO
EMBRACE WEAPONIZING
INTELLIGENCE, SPYING ON AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND YET DISMISSING
OBVIOUS CRIMINAL ACTS WHEN
COMMITTED BY THEIR OWN PARTY OR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, THEY MADE
THEMSELVES NEED A NOVEMBER
MIRACLE TO PULL OFF THE KIND OF